we have now delivered over 200 million
doses
to the european people so we are on
track
to achieve our objective of enough doses
being delivered in july to vaccinate 70
percent of the european adult population
close to 160 million europeans now have
already received
a first shot of the vaccine that's over
25 percent of the eu population
i'm glad to report that the legal
and the technical work on the eu travel
certificate
the vaccination certificate is on track
for the system to be operational in june
and therefore i was glad that i could
announce that we now concluded
the negotiations with biontech pfizer
for a new contract a new contract
looking
forward to the years 22 and 23.
the new contract secures 1.8 billion
doses of vaccines
sooner or later children and teenager
will be vaccinated for that
we have to prepare of course we have
discussed the uh role of the european
union
in the global vaccination effort
the european union is the pharmacy of
the world and
open to the world up to today in the
european union
400 million doses of vaccines have been
produced
and 50 of them 200 million doses have
been exported
to 90 different countries in the world
so we invite
others to do the same